más problemas para el presidente
sebastián piñera ahora de la mano de la
oposición chilena que presentó ante la
cámara de diputados- una acusación para
iniciar un juicio político en su contra
para destituirlo del cargo por su
implicación en los papeles de pandora es
absolutamente inaceptable que un
presidente de la república esté
utilizando su cargo para negocios
personales para favorecer a su familia
realizando operaciones en paraísos
fiscales todos los antecedentes de esta
acusación
permiten decir que va a haber un apoyo
mayoritario hace una semana la
investigación situó a piñera como uno de
los tres dirigentes en activo de américa
latina' señalados en los papeles en
estos se le acusaba por la participación
en la venta en 2010 de la minera dominga
que se hizo sin que el presidente
declarara la protección ambiental a
pesar de que la mina está cerca de una
reserva de pingüinos algo que el
mandatario negó rotundamente
los antecedentes estaba
incluyendo su precio forma de pago y
condiciones fueron conocidas por la
fiscalía por el tribunal de garantías y
por la corte de apelaciones
todos ellos determinaron en forma
consistente y unánime la inexistencia de
delitos y la inocencia de mi persona
pero la fiscalía nacional también cree
que hay pruebas en contra de piñera por
lo que hace cinco días comenzó una
investigación en su contra algo que se
suma el descontento del pueblo desde la
filtración de los archivos a
su renuncia una situación delicada para
el líder chileno cuyo futuro está ahora
en manos de la cámara de diputados y la
fiscalía